recording yeah hey guys we're back is
it's actually the last day of the
tournaments
I think we're behind a couple of games
we last went over around six and then
for this video we're gonna take a look
at Round seven mm-hmm
which was really painful for me and
really painless for you yeah oh yeah I
guess I'll start mine was relatively
quick and painless so going into this
round I'm on five out of six
and I think tied for second I'm playing
against another I am by the name of
Lucien Catalan karma choo and he has
been playing a lot of III lines in the
tournament as I noticed like on move
three without developing the dark square
Bishop so I prepared some of these lines
at home he kind of surprised me with
this move or door though Knight c3 I
thought okay well maybe he's gonna go
into like efore Kings Indian which he
according to the database hasn't played
in like 15 years so that's fine with me
but no then he does play III so this
transposes to your what you were
expecting well not exactly because what
I was preparing was a lot of lines with
b3 as well mm-hmm so I thought he might
do something like like this I don't know
I actually played this setup as black
against the Kings Indian attack
so like reversed yep on b7 yeah oh yeah
I think it's very just actually
interesting idea for White's play
against Kings Indian defense yeah it's
definitely playable and actually that's
one of the like this has become pretty
popular nowadays through um this move
order to avoid the Greenfeld mm-hmm
because if d5 y can still take and play
e4 because white hasn't committed Knight
c3 right and so black is forced to play
Knight b6 and because black has less
space it's hard to understand this whole
concept that in the Grune fella black
wants to trade
nights yeah because of the space
deficits Riley learn that like maybe a
year ago although which yeah this it
looks weird to play e3 e4 but likes just
good here if you keep all the minor
pieces on the board yeah yeah exactly
and but against Kings Indian players it
doesn't really make a huge difference
right because I'm putting the pawn as
your sex but people will still play this
position and it's a reverse Kings Indian
attack like some before move yeah
maybe black plays like c6 or rookie a
Tori five like Queen c2 radiates like
this and then Ricky one or a d1 and
white plays b4 and yeah it's a reverse
game
so like it should be fine there I mean
like his other options as well but then
when you went forward this before I
thought okay so that's what he wants he
wants play Bishop e2 and play like
against the Kings Indian his Mac which I
thought was reasonable so I thought for
a while to see if I should just play
Grunfeld then because now this is just a
normal version of her Greenfeld because
his night is on c3 did you ever play the
green field maybe once or twice okay
so hard decision to make over the board
yeah that's what I decided against it
because it could easily be a good one
but I also don't know the idea is that
well anyways I played d6
and then he plays b4 mm-hmm and this
more or less transpose is back into what
I prepared which was this idea to just
bust him with c5 nice I think this is a
good equalizer for black the ideas
whenever he takes at the D pawn he's
just gonna be opening up the diagonal
and if he pushes d5 then I think he's
just way to overextend you have 94
instead of u6 oh yeah I think this
probably works although sometimes I'm
wary of letting white just sacrifice it
just exams but I think it's a great
version because there's no exactly mr.
rate six but even after like e6000 a day
three I think that's a good move and
then I took Knight takes and Knights
if it takes like as an idea here to play
e5 in this kind of equalizes nice either
pushy for or if they take you know they
can't really dream of taking this pawn
I'm sure the viewers can work out the
tactics well it's always nice when
you're like fully developed and your
opponent has yet to cast when you just
bust open the center all right very
thematic ideas yeah yeah I felt I felt
very comfortable here
so knight c6 Bishop b2 I take on the
four he takes d4 I played a five
he took took Bishop e2 and you offered a
draw mmm so I was actually really torn
here because already I could feel like
he was unhappy with how the opening went
but objectively the the position is very
much equal as well and to be honest I've
actually don't have a lot of experience
in this structure with the three versus
two and I've played a couple times for
white and I feel like white is the one
always with kind of the long-term
chances to get the knight to c5 or d6
mm-hmm
now black his way to developed here to
be any worse but I don't know I felt
like in the long run strategically if I
miss play and I could easily just get a
much worse endgame all three was also
possible it seems like yeah so I figured
well tournaments going well it's better
to rest up do some like laundry answer
some you know so I took the draw and
that was that was it especially on the
day with the double round I mean it so
it makes sense you've done that twice as
tournaments take a quick draw in the
double yeah yeah great strategy
unfortunately for me I did not have a
quick draw at a very long and painful
loss which I already tried to suppress
from my memory but now we're gonna
unsuppressed it and take a look at what
what happens hopefully learn some lesson
from this game because I was better I
was playing a lower air player about
2150 younger kid who I played in the
blitz
oh no no just loves interrupting videos
with their updates so I played this kid
in the Blitz and this is the the same
kid I played in round 3 of this
tournament
that's right so I was already familiar
with their game I played the London
against him in the Blitz and I won the
exchange very early on then he came back
to beat me in this game I won material
early on then he again came back to be
me so I played the London again
realising that okay he wasn't
comfortable in the Blitz game so I might
as well try it in the Blitz he played
some lying with like e6 and c5 in this
game he played g6
which already made me happy because I
don't think he has any experience
playing like these early fianchetto
structures and I've been studying this
line a lot recently with Knight c3
preparing the early e4 I think this is
what we call the barre attack a pretty
trendy among like teams lately d5
preventing e4 and then I play this line
III Bishop g7 and h4 I remember when I
first studied this I thought it was just
dubious but it's actually really
interesting for whites one of the key
variations here is if black castles I
can just play h5 and then it's my ticket
five I'm happy to sack and whites just
better here I think the computer gives
like plus 1.5 or something like crazy
advantage
that's huge compensation is overwhelming
I've Bishop d3 Knight f3 Castle
queenside put it rook on each one and if
so if black doesn't castle are you still
gonna sacrifice this exchange so that's
the question like black like what
happened in the game he played a 6
mm-hmm which she was already thinking so
it was clear he was out of preparation
maybe he was scared of Knight b5 and I
was on my own here like cuz uh I've
never seen a 6 before I was prepared
against all their moves but then it's a
question do I still play age 5 I didn't
take too long here like I I realized
that if I play h5 and I take a gyro
ticket if I cheat a cage try point a
cage 5 I still have a lot of
compensation because D fives attacked so
I went for it oh yeah each five I'll
show one line try and explain why he
played a6 there's another common move
here for black c5
attempting to shift the focus to the
center rather than the kingside but then
I have a very annoying move Knight d5
which he only has one there's response
to Knight a six and this is usually a
good configuration for a white with the
knight on b5 against this 9 and a 6 the
Knights just kind of stuck here and I
would continue with like C 3 a 4 9 f3
and there's been some games in this line
I think white scores pretty well mm-hmm
but that didn't happen played a 6 I play
CH 5 and yeah I just calculated like a
few variations like after a take take
tick tick
I'm hitting the pawn on d5 and there's
some nice lines given that I have kind
of a hidden resource in this position
let's imagine he plays a6
sure I'm pretty sure I win material by
force I went upon by force in this
position it's just kind of a nice kind
of unexpected move can you play like
can you pick Bishop e5 and try to get in
should be five maybe that's possible
then he can trade and rook G is just
right hmm I don't get to stump you too
often so White's a plan went upon
essentially I haven't checked this with
the engine but I assume it's winning fun
I see
yeah I'm not sure I'm thinking Vishal
d3h six it's not yeah you have to
identify the target in this position
yeah there's uh just like simple like
Knight f3 Knight g5 yeah it's very clear
like a seven in h7 look like the obvious
targets right but the actual target is
c7 oc7
oh no did I break it oh no yeah okay
fine
this is some queen g4 queen g3 business
even simpler Queen H 2 and H 2 Wow a
backward attacking move Wow and the fact
that the night is on b8 he can't push
the C pawn mm-hmm I'm just gonna take on
c7 next move so I was secretly hoping
for something like this he can't even
play tonight a6 because I just the pawns
on e6 take away this so nice anyway that
didn't happen okay there's some other
lines to look at like if he plays c6
here I I think I would be happy I still
have Queen h2 if I want but I could play
like Knight f3 Castle kingside yeah she
isn't Queen into very annoying because
if Bishop c7 it's true he has Bishop f5
or something else but um would be
playable maybe like Bishop c7 9 a
fortnight b6 ideas right so it would be
a rich position for white he surprised
me
after h5 he played Bishop to g4 which I
didn't realize was possible I thought I
can just play f3 here it turns out to be
a playable line for both sides because
after Bishop take a try of g4 I'm not
winning material because he has g5 but I
thought this should be good for me
because I take on g5 I've forced this
bishop back now I have some nice pawn
structure my rook always on h1
pressuring the H file and I know I was
content with this position Knight to c6
not for another problem for him as I can
get the bishop pair anytime I want
so he played Queen b6 will go forward
several moves I defended b2 and attacked
his Queen he checks I place
three defending my nights plays 97 I
expand us back I go forward and then
after night see five I have somewhat of
a hidden threats I'm pretty sure he just
missed but the move he played made the
position a bit unclear and it actually I
I knew I should be better but it made
the game pretty complicated are you
cheating I I remember your game so I
know this is the first night on passant
I've ever seen the night on facade so
yeah after Pawnee five uh white to move
and night on Passat and it's it's an
easy move to overlook yeah I'm just
going into the heart of like his
territory right but I just go for ninety
six and this was the whole idea of night
c5 I just wanted to work the Queen in
the bishop and just win upon so I was
feeling pretty good here I don't think
e5 as objectively a good move um you
should probably do something else I
don't know maybe he can take on c5 and
and go for some idea like e5 yeah yeah
you take B pawn right yeah something
like this take tick b5 or even I mean I
think you're just strategically better
if you get your Bishop on this diagonal
like that's true actually
yeah and like blacks King doesn't really
have a safe place to go like wherever
the king of there's potential to attack
it so yeah I would even trade off the
light squared Bishop so if I was you to
get the B once ah it's very possible
yeah they can I stood a tional idea
started oh yeah rook could be one
forever weak pawn in b7 so he played e5
he allowed ninety-six and sometimes this
is a problem when at least when I play
lower rate of players as well make a
mistake but then they'll get the so
called accidental compensation and you
realized it like he he realized he made
a mistake but he realized the position
was
applicated enough and I think that gave
him some energy or some momentum to try
and fight back right and that's exactly
how he beat me in the Blitz game too so
I was being cautious like I uh okay I
take on g7 I bring the knight back this
was all relatively forced he takes one
f5 take and yeah I'm up a pawn but it's
very imbalanced like both Kings are not
the safest and it's two bishops versus
two knights my pawn on a five it could
be a strength it could be a weakness but
he played well from here he started with
h6 I shouldn't note that there's some
lion like if he takes on I think if he
takes on d4 I'd have to play Bishop f4
because he's threatening Queen g3 mm-hmm
so I would play Bishop f4 and then if he
plays Queen e7 I can't take with a pawn
if I take the C pawn I lose before so I
would take with the Queen this is sort
of what I was expecting but yeah he
played age six first and then I just
dropped back to nod covering g3 plays
rookie Yates I think one of the benefits
for him in this resulting position is
that his rooks come into play much
quicker
yeah my my rooks are like pointless in
this position and he gets a nice brownie
Yates after King f2 he plays with g8 so
it just seemed like he had better
harmony and then already I wasn't quite
sure what to do because it just feels
awkward like how do I develop my
LightSquared Bishop how do I get my
rooks into play if I ever play Bishop d3
he has something move like efore mhm
I wanted to play Bishop h3 but oh maybe
I should've played Bishop h3 I was
scared of some potential of him like
doubling up on one of the files yeah I
forget exactly what I was thinking here
though I really need to get one of your
routes to g1 right when they're
connected and the move I played I
thought was a good move when I played it
let's move rook h3
but I think it turned out to be too slow
and the fact that he already had like a
good setup for his pieces led to tactics
in his favor
I played rocketry because I wanted to
play Bishop g3 pressure the Queen and
pressure this pawn but then he play the
combination I completely overlooked
starting with taking on d4 now I pretty
much had to take with Queen I think
maybe I could have taken with one of the
pawns given what happened but then you
play the move I just completely forgot
about 94 strong strong tactical shots
given that when I take on e4 you take
some you threatening the Queen and he's
threatening rook to h4 so I wanted to
play Queen g1 here but then just wrote a
gauge for it knees crushing because
Queen g3 is coming yeah can we go to
that position after row before yeah yeah
this is what happened the game yeah yeah
I'm trying to figure out what to do here
so I still thought I was okay and
there's really only one move I think
white should play in this position if
you want to not cheat and try and find
it and the one move I think just leads
to an unclear position
yeah
there's really not too many options to
consider yeah I mean I I know the move
you played oh you know it okay yeah I
mean I think it's only moved a game way
yeah just trying to see if there is
anything like Bishop g3 but rook takes
g3 oh yeah I want it to and then I was
telling like maybe Queen h8 in that
position
ah because I don't see any immediate
like threats he has but I think you can
just take on h3 and then run with the
king
yeah take so for example Bishop g3
mm-hmm
rook to e3 you want to play Queen a
chance
yeah what's material material is equal
fish um
I mean can you just take on e3 he's for
any Queen up for me but Queen h7 check
and then sir g7 at the very least well
you can take on g7 and oh that's and
then we get some ender where his light
is coming in also I'm wondering if we
can just take on h6 with our queen with
a queen oh well yeah I mean it's not my
king so like my King looks pretty naked
here yeah I'm wondering like this move
Knight f6 looks so fancy nobody for
coming like it's about to be a fork oh
man no matter no matter what you can
take the rook three different ways but
then you get king and queen for its
Knight g4 okay I would have to just take
both rooks then like Queens yeah and
something similar happened in the game I
thought what I played was the best try
Queen take e4 give and I have Bishop c4
Chuck and I thought I was still playing
for a win here the problem is okay his
Queen d2 King g1 and then take the
problem is that the Queen Knight combo
is very very strong and attacking Wow
wait so many pieces came off the board
yeah so
should we do a slow-motion replay yeah
okay slow-motion replay starting in this
because it starts with this night
sacrifice exactly it started with taking
on d4 right no the position transforms
immensely I didn't even see this coming
like when I play rotates tree okay if I
was a strong player it maybe I a
stronger player I should calculate this
whole line with the material imbalance
but it just was a complete shock 94 well
slow motion tick tick tick tick
maybe the viewers can watch the video at
like half the speed there's some
extension for that anyway Queen d2 is a
powerful move so you got the two rooks
the bill then he gets the piece back so
ends up with Toric's for a queen right
and pawns are equal and I thought like
two rooks plus a bishop should be decent
against I'd and queen but the the issue
is like both combinations are pretty
powerful right and the big problem for
me in this position his knight has a
very clear path to f3 yeah and it's so
difficult to stop I don't have any way
to control d5 here because Bishop g3
runs them to queen take III so
essentially I had to try and play around
the Knights I haven't checked this with
engine I don't know who's better here
I played Bishop f2 which I thought was a
decent move defending the pawn
threatening taking on each six
he plays 95 they take on each six and
then Queen e2 um forgot a lot he think
we need to but maybe it's a decent move
he wants to play like queen g4 I play
rook h3 planning to me queen g4 or with
with rook g3 and then it was a long
fight I think some of these moves I
won't give too much commentary on he won
a - I played Bishop h4 but you didn't
have rogue g3 here wait a minute rook g3
we need you back
I saw cookie okay I scared me for a
moment yeah I was very
yeah and then I'm kind of stuck right
because my bishop has no moves because
Queeny Queeny h2 would be mates my rook
is tied down in f1 and then he just has
some simple plan like b6 h b 6 a 5 yeah
so I realized I had to try and untangle
play Bishop h4 the idea being maybe I
want to play f6 I also want to play
rough g3 now it plays King 7 I also
wanted to bring my bishop to to f4 where
I thought it was a more stable piece
yeah and control the h2 square so you
played a good move 95 can this a 3
square is so annoying and then we get to
a critical moment after a Bishop f4 903
check I have a choice between rook take
f3 and King h1 I thought for a while
here and I think I played the wrong move
it might just be that both moves are
losing let me show what happened and
then we'll go back just see maybe what
could have been better
I played king h1 which I think right I
just overlooked his idea a very strong
move for black Queen e2 yeah my back
yeah my rook actually runs out of
squares when I initially played King h1
I thought I'm just defending here
because I control I control the first
rank in the H file and he has no way to
check the King this night is so far
checking distance away his queen can't
check the king but he has a very very
strong relatively simple move here that
I I missed so black to move like to move
huh yes
[Music]
yeah I guess 91 is the only way mm-hmm
ones so sad and for some reason I
thought I could just defend with rook g3
the problem is that he meets me almost
by force no following f1 King h2 there
would be Knight f3 Ciroc g1 Queen h3
Bishop h2 my bike can get smothered and
then we're not three in the Nieman's so
that was sad
so maybe I should have taken and played
this position where I do have to pass
pawns
I spent a long time thinking here and I
rejected this line because he wins he
starts winning my Queen side plants
Queen e1 and then take I don't have any
time for you for because he has Queen c2
and taking on e4 I was trying to make
this line work where I could play King
g3 here he takes on before I play King
g4 and just start trying to like do this
stuff I calculated pretty far and I got
to this position and I just assumed what
I just assumed that black should easily
be winning with him move like King G
aids because his a pawn is too fast but
maybe there's a chance I've miss
evaluated like because these positions
can be deceiving like maybe I could play
rook c7 it just seems unclear or it
seems it's just so close to losing but
you there should be 5 still so King g5 a
2-bit should be 5 right so I just I
thought there would be some win for oh
he can't take on f4 cuz I have rook c8
check so a2 but yeah I should be winning
this would have been an interesting
position though is maybe like I might
have some perpetual like between the 8th
and 7th rank yeah
anyway some lines analyzed for her later
let's go to the game because he found 91
and then I'm just losing but I thought I
put up some resistance but he not work
age 7 I did the best I could
we'll go forward pretty quickly here he
traded off the pawns
I should note he was in big-time trouble
like most of this game like even by what
is this like out of the opening like by
move 20 he probably had mm-hmm like 15
minutes left
oh wow so just so I got increment the
whole game and then at this point he was
like below 2 minutes but every move just
playing on increment yeah and there's
never a point where he like he sped up
to play a few quick moves like he could
have done that like play some checks and
get some at a time but like every move
he was playing a verging like about 30
seconds so anyway I still had hope here
because my rook and Bishop coordinates
in his Pawnee for his potential weakness
and then around here I was feeling happy
because his King got really awkward and
I thought I could win the e4 pawn like
he has to play king c5 here saw their
eyes that I have like King c4 I've rook
d4 right in King e6 I probably have like
rook d6 check so here I was having a lot
of hope
I played King g4 I just wanted to walk
around and win the pawn and then maybe
someday sack my Bishop for the C pawn
sure and get some like good drawing rook
pawn burst Queen ending unfortunately
that never happened and he found a
really strong idea at some points Queen
h1 was strong and then after rook b8
brought his king to the a file King f5
and then he just played a very strong
move here and I was still feeling good
like I thought okay is queen is tied
down to the e4 pawn
I thought if he pushes c5 I don't know
maybe I'd have liked King oh yeah if you
push the c5 I would have king e5 and I
would walk my king in and my king would
be attacking both of his pawns so he
played just a very strong move I won't
make you find it if you always want to
pause the video and try and find like
the best practical move for Queen h5
check and Queen HF that's nice it's so
sad I forgot my King gets made it on e4
I can't take the pawn because Queen d5
mates and then my King has to move to
some awkward square like e6
he plays Queen d5 and you get a cut and
my King gets out of play and then he
just pushes the C pawn at this point
yeah it just goes downhill I tried to
resist but he had some good technique so
I played on I played on for a couple
reasons
because I saw okay first of all I saw
his uh his last round blitz game you
remember that of course we're okay so
quick side note my opponent this game he
was playing for first place in the blitz
tournament the last round he had queen
versus rook oh yeah pure again King
Queen risking rook
he had the Queen and he plundered his
queen and lost the position so I was
hoping to at the very least guess I
wasn't even like he like he hung a
skewer it was so yeah there's still some
hope here to get that end game right
haven't redeem himself I can like sacked
a bishop for both pawns or something
right
the other reason why I was playing on is
cuz in my game I had some stalemate
trick mhm and actually the final
position in my game with him it was a
draw because my rook like continually
see check super ticket exactly but I had
flagged like 15 moves earlier and he
just never saw the flag so I like I was
gonna try and offer him a draw and see
he takes it and he saw them I flagged so
there's hope like when you have a ruck
there's always hope to play on I was
also playing on cuz like he was still
below a minute like he was still moving
very slowly right and then okay like at
this point it's just resigned a bull I
just wasn't sure the last moment cuz
there there was a weird there was a kind
of a weird finish to this game okay I
was praying for Brooke c7 check but
anyway let's get to the weird finish
[Music]
okay so actually in this position I
calculated that the weird finish like I
intentionally played rookie six because
I saw the next like three moves which
were most expected and in this position
um he was he like reached over the board
to grab his there's like another queen
and he was holding on to his Queen so we
got to this position he took on g6 and
then he was holding on to his queen and
there's a rule which I I didn't realize
I actually didn't know but like how how
this touch move apply when you promote a
pawn mm-hmm
so I played this move King h8 and
actually went up and asked a tournament
director if if he's touching a queen off
the board does he have to promote to the
queen or he's touching anything off the
board really exactly so I thought King
h8 it's like the last and yeah for many
of you watching this if you haven't seen
the protests League video or the micro
Chesley game I the game back in was it
back in January or February where I I
had this almost exact same scenario
where Queen take rook on and some square
like g6 I play King h8 and my opponent
pre moves upon move of course in
classical chess they don't they can't
pre move
so it doesn't work but he was touching
the Queen so later I found out after the
game that touch move doesn't apply until
the promoted piece touches the promotion
square once the piece actually enters
the game I would have felt that anyway
time to draw game like that I mean that
rule is so vague like what if he's
touching multiple pieces example yeah
and it's kind of a dirty like I would
have felt very dirty if he would have
appealed I would have liked okay you win
but okay he he saw the last trick he
played Queen h6 and then yeah that's how
it ended so it was a painful game but
because I had this kind of funny last
trick at the end I didn't feel so bad
but it was still still disappointing
that I felt like after I played 96 I was
in full control but the position was
just so unclear and sometimes that's how
you beat higher rated players you just
even if you overlooked something you got
a position where it's it's chaotic and
it's out of their control exactly and I
lost control after like he found this
nice move what is this 94 yeah chess is
rough you played like he deserved he
deserved the win like he he found this
tactic than he was able to grind down
the game so rough tournaments this was
this was already two days ago is this a
double round which exactly it took you
literally painful yeah yeah I lost both
both games that day you managed the day
much better winning and then with a
quick draw yeah so we're a bit behind
with the videos I think we'll end this
recording and then record the round 8
and then I'll schedule some sort of post
but for now I'll see you guys in the
next video yes